july is quickly shaping up to be the
hottest month of the year and we're not
talking about the weather
netflix's upcoming release schedule is a
firestorm of hot new movies and shows
from bingeable new seasons of fan
favorite shows to great new netflix
original horror thrillers
there's definitely a lot to get excited
about in the upcoming weeks
here are all the new movies and shows
coming to netflix in july 2018.
the legacy of a whitetail deer hunter
from danny mcbride and jody hill the duo
behind hbo's vice principles the legacy
of a white-tailed deer hunter follows
aging hunting legend and tv personality
buck ferguson as he heads up into the
mountains to reconnect with his son
with buck's cameraman don tagging along
well i mean it has been two years buck
though you know what are you human
calendar mr trapper keeper i know how
long it's been
sacred games season one as india's first
netflix original series
sacred games continues as services mo of
bringing international talent
onto their diverse lineup the show is
described as a dark crime thriller
and is based on the best-selling novel
of the same name
samantha season one netflix made a great
decision when they brought on brazilian
series 3
and it looks like their intent on
tapping the country for even more of its
programming
samantha is an upcoming brazilian show
about a former 80s child star who's
desperate to reach the level of fame she
once had
leading her on some wild adventures as
she does everything in her power to get
back into the spotlight
somebody feed phil the second course
most people probably know phil rosenthal
is the creator of the long-running
sitcom hit everybody loves raymond but
in recent years he's been on a different
sort of adventure
in somebody feed phil rosenthal jets off
to exotic locations
check out the local culture and cuisine
basically it's like every other travel
food show with the distinction that
rosenthal isn't an expert on either
culture or cuisine he's just a guy who
likes food
nothing wrong with that and you know we
like anything on a stick
comedians and cars getting coffee
freshly brewed
jerry steinfeld's and demanding talk
show about comedians and cars getting
coffee
is rolling back into netflix with a
freshly brewed batch of today's hottest
comedians
the series fifth collection freshly
brewed will see seinfeld chatting with
dave chappelle
kate mckinnon and zach galifianakis to
name a few
first team juventus season 1 part b
sports fans had a ball with the first
part of netflix's 2018 docu-series first
team juventus
which follows the juventus football club
during their 2017-2018 season
each 40-minute episode goes behind the
scenes to take an intimate look
of the players and coaches of the
italian soccer team
inside the world's toughest prisons
season 2. they may not be too deadly to
safely get a camera crew inside
but the prisons that journalists paul
connolly visits in inside the world's
toughest prisons definitely wreak of
danger
in the first season connolly posed as a
prisoner in four separate lock-ups
around the world
living face-to-face with dangerous
inmates season two will see the same
approach with the new presenter
raphael rowe a journalist to himself
actually spent 12 years in prison
the skin of the wolf this spanish movie
made its u.s premiere in march 2018 at
the miami film festival
the story follows a lonely hunter who's
the last remaining resident
of an abandoned town at the top of a
mountain don't let the spanish subtitles
hold you back because there aren't many
lines to read
the skin of the wolf features precious
little dialogue with long stretches
containing none at all
yet there's a raw hypnotic quality to
the film that keeps it from getting
boring
white fang netflix's newest animated
film is bringing jack london's timeless
tale to a whole new audience
like the book the narrative of the film
is told from the perspective of white
fang
a half-wolf sled dog who's adopted by a
native american tribe and learns to
become a vicious fighter
nick offerman paul giamatti and rashida
jones lend their voices to the cast
make sure you check out the legacy of a
whitetail deer hunter sacred game season
1
samantha season 1 somebody feed fail the
second course
comedians and cars getting coffee
freshly brewed first team juventus
inside the world's toughest prison
season 2 the skin of the wolf and white
fang when they all drop onto netflix
on july 6th drug lords season 2
a look at the most notorious criminal
kingpins in history
drug lords honed in on famous names like
pablo escobar
frank lucas and kath pettingell dubbed
granny evil for a iron grip on the
melbourne drug trade
season 2 will raise the stakes with even
more of the head honchos of crime
from el chapo to jamaican gangster
christopher coke look for it on july
10th
how it ends starring theo james and
forrest whitaker how it ends as an
action thriller that follows a man who
sets off on a journey across the country
to find his pregnant girlfriend after a
mysterious apocalyptic event
check it out on july 13th sugar rush
netflix has been piling on the cooking
shows lately with nailed it and ugly
delicious premiering in early 2018.
now sugar rush is joining the roster in
this cooking competition
chef adriano zumbo and bakery owner
candice nelson
judge participants who are racing
against the clock to whip up the best
desserts
it should be a sweet time and you can
catch it all on july 13th
bonus family season two in this swedish
series
family takes center stage as two
divorcees with kids move in with each
other
and bring all their emotional baggage
with them with everybody living under
the same roof there's bound to be plenty
of drama and comedy alike
take a look at season two and it drops
on july 15th
the joel mchale show with joel mckay or
part two while joel mchale's green
screen celebrity rants originally aired
as weekly episodes
netflix is changing up the format for
the next batch dropping them all on the
same day the series sees community star
joel mchale poking fun at popular shows
reality tv and celebrities interspersed
with scripted comedy bits look for part
2 to land on july 15th
amazing interiors with the world's most
extraordinary homes
netflix took viewers on a whirlwind tour
around the globe to visit a few of the
craziest looking homes in existence
with amazing interiors the format
continues only this time
the crazy is all inside what will you
find when you walk through the doors of
these homes
find out on july 20th
[Music]
dark tourist instead of visiting the
usual cultural highlights around the
world
dark taurus pinpoints the planet's most
morbid settings
such as abandoned nuclear reactors and
haunted forests
journalist and filmmaker david farrier
leads the church
promising a weird journey into the
unexpected take the plunge on july 20th
father of the year david spade headlines
as coming-of-age comedy which sees two
boys coming home from college when they
get into an argument about whose father
could beat up the other's father
one of their dads steps up to the
challenge hi jinx and sue
take a look on july 20th last
chance you for two seasons netflix
tagged the longest of troubled teams of
eastern mississippi community college
or emcc fought to return to division 1
status
and achieve their football dreams
nicknames last chance u
emcc offered many of these players their
last shot at redemption
for the third season netflix is
releasing a two-parter
the first takes a look at the players
who left emcc after the first two
seasons and is called appropriately
last chance u emcc and life after the
second the last chance u
indie part 1 starts up the new season at
a new school
independence community college in kansas
the expectations are lower but the
stakes are higher than ever
look for both to land on july 20th
the warning keep your eyes peeled for
spanish thriller the warning
when a 10 year old boy finds a note at a
gas station that seems to predict his
death he'll have to team up with a
mysterious stranger to figure out what's
going on before it's too late
get ready for all the twists and turns
when the warning shows up on july 24th
extinction this sci-fi thriller stars
michael pena as a father who's recurring
nightmares about an alien invasion come
true
when actual aliens attack the planet
he'll have to fight to keep his family
safe from the extraterrestrial threat
lizzie kaplan and luke cage's mike
coulter co-star look for extinction on
july 27th
roman empire reign of blood master of
rome
netflix's docudrama series roman empire
reign of blood
has spent two years training fans with
its historical look at the beginnings of
the fall of rome
the series uses actors and sets to play
out the drama while the occasional voice
over or talking head pops in to provide
documentary style commentary
on what's going on the upcoming roman
empire reign of blood master of rome
will follow the same format
and this time the focus is on julius
caesar queued up on july 27th
orange is a new black season six for
five seasons
piper and her friends have regaled
audiences in one of the most engaging
and original shows in recent memory
we've seen relationships form flourish
and wither all within the halls of
litchfield prison
judging by the brief teaser for the new
season the show will pick up right where
fans last saw piper and the remaining
inmates in the season 5 cliffhanger
look for it on july 27th
the bleeding edge through candid
interviews with patients and medical
professionals the bleeding edge paints a
terrifying picture of medical devices
rush through safety testing and
installed in hospitals across the
country
there's nothing more terrifying than a
medical horror story so it's sure to be
an eye-opening experience
take a look on july 27th a very secret
service season two
this goofy spy comedy is sort of like
the french answer to get smart
with both hard-hitting drama and absurd
comedy the first season of a very secret
service built a loyal if small fan base
the second season promises more of the
same don't miss it when it arrives on
netflix on july 30th
terrace house opening new doors part
three inexplicably one of netflix's more
popular shows
terrace house operates on the basic
premise that a reality show
doesn't need any scripting whatsoever to
draw in viewers this japanese series is
low-key drama-free
and utterly hypnotizing for no
discernible reason part 3 of the
spin-off opening new doors hits on july
31st
original stand-up comedy netflix is
offering a different take on comedy this
july
in addition to two full-length specials
netflix is also releasing a stand-up
collection
titled the comedy lineup which will see
multiple comedians take the stage for
short sets
that shows up on july 3rd and you can
also catch jim jeffries this is me now
on july 13th
followed by eliza schlesinger elder
millennial on july 24th
that wraps up all the netflix originals
arriving in july 2018
so let's turn to everything else being
added to the streaming service next
month
[Music]
new movies as far as netflix is
concerned the blockbuster season
officially begins on july 1st
the first of the month for dorm of
classic action films like the jurassic
park trilogy
the boondock saints and van helsing july
1st will also see the arrival of some
great dramas
such as menace to society and we own the
night
later in the month you can look for blue
valentine on the fifth gone baby gone on
the 12th and her on the 29th
for laughs don't miss ryan reynolds 2014
dark comedy the voices
which sees reynolds as a slightly
psychopathic blue-collar worker
you know i'm a talking cat there's no
such thing everything i see
is really you it's true buddy they tell
you
what that's arriving on the first
alongside the return of beau burnham
stand up special
what finally kevin hart let me explain
this dropping on the 13th
netflix is also rolling out plenty of
options for the family to watch together
look for finding netherlands the two
scooby-doo movies and the princess
diaries on july 1st
followed by disney's bolt on the 22nd
unfortunately july is going to be slim
pickings for the horror fans in the room
there are only two upcoming films on the
docket deceived arrives on july 1st
and scream 4 arrives on july 7th
new television if netflix is coming up
short in some of their movie categories
they're more than making up for it with
their television selection you can
escape the summer heat with new seasons
of blue bloods
hawaii 5-0 ncis and madame secretary on
the 1st
july 2nd sees the arrival of season 4 of
the good witch
and season 1 of the sinner and july 6
will herald the addition of the fosters
season 5.
finally july 28th will bring the
dysfunctional gallagher family back home
as season 8 of shameless arrives
thanks for watching click the looper
icon to subscribe to our youtube channel
plus
check out all this cool stuff we know
you'll love too